ein spiel herausgebracht das heißt
minecraft vierkampf
h
löw meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der micro effekt heute am dienstag ich
habe endlich meine audio einstellungen
richtig angepasst ich denke dass die
stimme jetzt wieder so sollten wir hab
ich grad kameras gezogen hätte mich noch
hallo hallo hallo hallo hier hört mich
noch ich hoffe die stimme wird wieder so
sein wie ihr die ausging welchen anderen
damaligen videos kennt ich hatte dass er
kurzzeitig umgestellt wegen der nachbarn
aber die bauern jetzt irgendwie nicht
mehr oder zumindest für den moment
gerade nicht ich hoffe mal die fange
jetzt nicht wieder an
sonst gehe ich einfach kurz zu den rüber
so wie ich das einmal gemacht habe als
ich mit staffel etwas aufgenommen habe
und diese nachbarn der die berliner zu
tag seitdem denkt ich schreibe was ich
mal eben kurz und hau denen einfach mal
gegen die wand
aber das ist heute nicht das thema
sondern ich habe mir wieder fünf fakten
rausgesucht die allesamt cool sind und
wir fangen direkt an mit fact nummer
eins ich würde mich freuen wenn du bis
männer dran bleiben würde und ich würde
mich außerdem freuen wenn ihr euer leben
genießen würde weil das ist das
wichtigste
und wer wollte ich gar nicht sagen da
hinten steht der erste effekt ist ganz
simpel und zwar sind bruchsteinen und
erde die ersten beiden blöcke die je in
minecraft implementiert wurden also
einfach dieser stein hier beziehen sie
nicht erde sondern der gras block und
der nicht der normale steinen sondern
der ganz normale bruchstein der sieht
nämlich so aus in dem text schmeckt was
ich jetzt gab benutzer sich benutzer des
packs dass beide sind die ersten blöcke
die minecraft drin waren und zwar sah
die welt einfach so aus da war hier
einfach bruchstein und darüber war
einfach die erde in komplett grün und
auch die texturen waren noch anders
und da waren dann teilweise auch nicht
diese komische blüten drauf sondern so
sah die komplette welt einfach aus das
war ganz am anfang so ich blende euch
jetzt auch noch mal ein screenshot davon
ein wie die welt damals aussah also ein
ganz simpler erst effekt einfach dass
die ersten beiden steine in minecraft
überhaupt die ersten beiden blöcke waren
eher der waren gras block und gras block
und bruchsteinen sorgt gras block und
bruchstein erster fällt erstmal in
blöcke jeden minecraft
immer weiter mit 4 2 so freuen ich habe
ich hier schon drei türme aufgebaut und
zwar immer entsteinen obsidian und
grundgestein also bedrock observieren
und enstone und wenn ich jetzt mal einen
ender drachen spawnen dann wisst ihr
eigentlich dass der ändert recken alles
mit sich wegreißt alle möglichen blöcke
und zwar außer diese drei werke edition
der fig da einfach durch wenn er jetzt
vielleicht zurückkommen und mich
irgendwie toten möchte seht ihr schon
wenn er gleich irgendwie auf dem boden
fliegen sollte dann macht er einen tanz
vorführen oder was macht er da gerade
wieso haut er ab
rudi der haut einfach ab was ist los mit
dem also ich weiß nicht ich hoffe ich
kann es euch hier nochmal zeigen hier
ist ein inländer dragon der macht hier
teilweise dass hier der beides setzt
beispielsweise kaputt gemacht und der
fliegt damit gesehen der weg durch diese
drei blöcke durch wenn wir allerdings
jetzt auf den boden fliegen sollte was
der jetzt mal macht da seht ihr schon da
macht er hier die blöcke kaputt
allerdings kann er durch diese drei
türme durchfliegen und zwar durch
bedrock obsidian und ernster und ihr
seht schon hier der reißt mir alles
unter meinen füßen einfach weg aber da
kann der durch fliegen also das sind die
einzigen drei blöcke wurde ändert rache
durch fliegen kann und halt auch noch
die luft die luft ist ja auch ein blog
da dass die luft ist unter anderem der
einzige blog in dem ich leben kann weil
im wasser er trinke ich in der lava
ersticke ich und nur in der luft die als
solider oder unsolider block gilt meine
ich kann auch der minecraft charakter
überleben zu luft kommen jetzt übrigens
gleich noch und zwar der dritte effekt
handelt jetzt von der luft fährt grad
müllwagen her und es ist gerade halb
zwölf in der woche an einem sonntag das
ist irgendwie sehr komisch ich hoffe das
wird man nicht in der tonspur nachher
aber wir machen einfach mal weiter mit
dem dritten fact und zwar kann man luft
platzieren luft ist nicht nur ein blog
der einfach irgendwie hier so da sondern
luft es wirklich als richtiger blog
angesehen und den kann ich auch irgendwo
hinsetzen das heißt wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise sarges adblock und dann
muss jetzt xyz eingeben und dann eher
und dann kann ich dann luft platzieren
ihr seht schon hier meine koordinaten
sind einmalig geht man eben set blogger
- 197 dann 63 da gebe ich aber mal 62
ein damit der blog unter mir entfernt
wird
- 356 und dann eher und dann seht ihr
schon das unter mir beziehungsweise hier
wird dann der block gerade entfernt und
zwar genau hier ist eigentlich dieser
punkt den ich quasi grad anvisiert habe
das ganze kann hier beispielsweise
nochmal eingeben mit der 61 und dann
seht ihr schon dass der block darunter
jetzt entfernt wird und dementsprechend
so weiter wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
mal die 60 1 gb darunter wird der block
entfernt der wird allerdings nicht
entfernt also nicht die treue sondern
der wird einfach ersetzt durch den r
block und zwar luft wird wirklich als
block angesehene minecraft ich kann
erhalten nur durch ihn hindurch schlagen
und so weiter und so fort
und das ganze kommt uns quasi gar nicht
so vor aber luft ist wirklich auch ein
blog der einfach keine textur hat und
einfach keine keine umrandungen oder
irgendwie so aber luft es auch ein blog
und das ist auch schon fact nummer drei
und ich muss mich wirklich beeilen heute
wieder mit den fake sie fühle mich wie
alberto aber es ist wirklich so freuen
das ist halb zwölf und ich habe morgen
für uni und ich habe gerade den erfolg
inventur erzählt feck nummer vier ist
eine sache die eigentlich jeder schon
kennen müsste man sich allerdings
darüber noch nie wirklich gedanken
gemacht hat glaube ich und zwar ich
mache einen stein kaputt es kommt dieser
sound und ich mache einen spinnennetz
kaputt und dann kommt dieser sound das
sind genau die gleichen sound ich weiß
nicht wieso nur yang nicht für die
spinnennetze irgendwie den sound
genommen hat wie sonst oder irgendwie
oder irgendwie sowas wie halt irgendwie
sondern sollten so ein spinnennetz sound
keine ahnung
die irgendwie sowas oder so ich weiß
nicht wieso mojang da einfach den
gleichen sound genommen wie man bei den
schweinen genommen hat ich verstehe es
einfach nicht wo man hier ein stein und
hier ein spinnennetz
ich verstehe es einfach nicht also es
ist natürlich auch infekt und ihn kennen
wahrscheinlich auch schon viele aber
effekt ist es halt trotzdem aber ich
verstehe es einfach nicht wieso mojang
sowas gemacht hat das ist einfach nur
blöd faul oder vielleicht hat auch
irgendein trifft kriegen trifft krebs
vielleicht hat doch irgendeinen grund
dafür aber ich sehe jetzt erstmal
eigentlich keinen grund für deswegen
keine ahnung wieso
hier das biome sehr schön ich liebe
immer das savanne bio das sieht so
unglaublich toll aus mit dem schildern
das sieht einfach keine adobe direkt in
street view
das ist nummer vier steine abbauen hält
sich genauso an die spinnennetze abbauen
ich weiß einfach nicht warum freuen wenn
irgendwer von euch eine erklärung dazu
hat oder irgendwann andere ist dann will
ich mich darüber freuen wenn wir das in
kommentare schreiben würde und es sich
ja unfassbar tolles mit dem crusader
apropos shader ich habe so ein top 5
shader video gemacht das könnt ihr euch
anschauen das ist auf einem kanal aber
sonst würde ich sagen das war feck
nummer vier und jetzt kommen wir auch
schon direkt zu
nummer fünf ist eine sache die jetzt
gerade schon eingeblendet und zwar seht
ihr einen screenshot eingeblendet und
zwar hatten dezember 2009 das glaube ich
ein spiel herausgebracht das heißt
minecraft 4k das ist eigentlich so wie
minecraft nur das ganze ist 4k also
nicht 4k bildqualität sondern einfach 4
km größe das teil ist halt wirklich 4
kilobyte groß dieses spiel unterscheidet
sich in minecraft von daher weil es
einfach extrem klein ist und deswegen
als weil es so kleint nehmen weil es
beispielsweise keinen himmel hat also
der himmel ist einfach nur schwarz
dann gibt es sehr wenige blöcke wie
beispielsweise nur gras erde ziegel und
noch ein paar andere sachen laub gibt es
noch unter anderem es gibt keinen tag
und nacht man kann die steuerung nicht
ändern das laub verschwindet nicht wenn
keine blöcke mehr in der umgebung sind
von hopp von holz oder so das ist total
simpel das spiel kann man sich auch
nicht mehr runter laden das hat er
damals gemacht für ihn sondern was mache
ich überhaupt hat er damals gemacht für
irgend so ein wettbewerb ich weiß auch
gar nicht mehr genau wider hieß man kann
sich das spiel auch nicht mehr runter
laden in minecraft wiki wird zwar noch
darauf verwiesen allerdings ist die
seite irgendwie down von mojang oder
irgendwie so und man kann sich das sei
dementsprechend dann nicht mehr
herunterladen das spiel heißt minecraft
4k und das ist eigentlich eine ganz
interessante sache und zwar die grafik
war einfach so extrem simpel einfach so
minecraft in noch viel einfacher richtig
komisch gemacht keine ahnung wieso der
sowas gemacht hat einfach für so ein
wettbewerb oder so und ich weiß nicht
wieso man das nicht mehr unterlagen kann
sonst hätte ich euch natürlich daraus
das video dann gezeigt aus dieser
version
aber das war feck nummer fünf jahre
freunde wenn euch das video gefallen hat
dann würde ich mich definitiv über eine
bewertung freuen der zeitnehmer das
video euch gefallen hat der sie mehr
davon
ja ich habe überlegt die effect serie
demnächst mal so ein wenig anders
aufzubauen irgendwie sowas wie 56 über
minecraft mops oder irgendwie sowas
einfach nur damit nicht immer so total
komische sachen kommen und ich dann mal
sachen außen bikini mal sachen selbst
rausfinden und ja ihr könnt mir
dementsprechend weiterhelfen wenn ihr
ideen habt einfach in die kommentare
schreiben
wenn ihr facts kennt einfach und in die
kommentare schreiben und dann sehen wir
uns morgen wieder bei einem anderen
video